hi everyone my name is Sally I'm a
software engineer here at Google at Q
Khan and here with me now is Luis and
engineer on sto Luis can you introduce
yourself hi I'm lui Ryan I work on issue
for Google I've been working on since
the start of the project and I'm just
really excited to be here and talk about
the project so we've been hearing a lot
about SEO what is it and how does it fit
into the queue Khan in kubernetes world
ok so a is what we call a service mesh
which is you know a very abstract
definition but what really is tio does
is it gives you a way to kind of elevate
the the networking concepts and allow
you to manage you know how services
micro services VMS on all these
different types of workloads communicate
with each other and apply policies those
things and extracts ulema tree from that
traffic so you get a much deeper set of
insights about how your you know your
your network is behaving how your
applications are behaving and use that
to kind of drive operational practices
and improve the security posture of your
your deployments got it so so it sounds
like before sto folks were basically
building custom logic into every single
application to do things like logging
and network routing and with this geo
all of that gets extracted out of the
applications in one single control plane
yes yes so the the goal is to kind of
unburden application developers from all
these common concerns that you know
depending on how many platforms you are
building your application code in you
would see you know a high degree of
variability in the the completeness or
the quality of those you know
integrations with other pieces of the
infrastructure and so you know sto hopes
to kind of give a high uniform base of
those set of capabilities out-of-the-box
to infrastructure operators so ideally
application developers have to think a
lot less about those concerns and by
definition their application code
becomes simpler over time by doing so
and so it creates this nice separation
of concerns in operations for companies
got it and is it Co something that folks
should start with from the beginning or
something they should consider a later
down the line as they begin to get
larger so on we see both at the same
time almost by definition right there
are obviously lots and lots of really
really large deployments out there you
know
but we also see companies adopting sto
from the beginning just because people
recognize the value it has in the
developmental operations practices so we
kind of see these two different
deployment modalities you know when they
adopt Greenfield and it's it's just very
natural and they don't have to go
through the object processes but sto has
to be able to you know be taken on board
by a large deployment and incrementally
rolled out so we make sure we have
features that are there to support those
types of deployments got it and what is
the current status officio so it's do
you know we went 100 in the summer of
last year and we've been kind of pushing
you know like any project patch releases
to support you know stability and
reliability and scale the next major
release we have coming is in the end of
sometime in January the 1.1 release will
be some you know major kind of
performance and architectural
improvements to the product so yeah it's
it's on a you know like any project it's
moving forward we're adding features
it's scaling up or you know onboarding
customers and uh yeah it's just moving
along and I heard recently that gke
announced beta support for sto can you
talk a little bit about that yes so what
are we working on this we kind of
announced it at next last year and it
went through an alpha program and you
know we just had the beta announcement
you know just providing a nice kind of
unified out-of-the-box installation and
management experience around this do
four to make it easy for GK customers to
start using its features I mean you know
we're really excited to get that in the
hands of customers and get that feedback
you know because you know it's do an
open source projects right without kind
of some help in install you have it to
do a bit of work and so on on GCP itself
we can you know take away some of that
that installation headache for people
and just make their experience you so
what parts of history does gke manage is
that the deployment
or does it go beyond that so currently
it's the installed right and the upgrade
and particularly the upgrade is
important right we will make sure that
the the system automatically upgrades as
we add new capabilities and new releases
over time we'll make the system even
more managed and you know that will
include the ability to scale up the
amount of traffic and the number of pods
and workloads and other things that gke
handles and handle Multi cluster
deployments and other more complex
topologies and in terms of open source I
have no sto has a lot of contributions
for multiple companies and independent
folks can you talk about the community
and what's going on there yeah so it's -
is born as a community effort and so you
see you know not just google but IBM Red
Hat pivotal we use the envoy proxy from
lift which obviously Google is also
heavily invested in so yeah there's a
really large community I've been
wandering around talking to people at
the booths here and finding out about
integrations they've written with this
do that I didn't know existed so it's
great to see the kind of organic you
know groundswell of community support
around the project but yeah it's it's
very community driven we run very much
like kubernetes does and our processes
and our governance so yeah it's it's an
open project we're proud of the fact
that you know we're helping to push
open-source forward well it sounds
awesome let's shift gears a little bit
and talk about cube con this is not your
first cube con this is not my first cube
con though each cube con does seem to
get exponentially larger so the it's
it's amazing you know I I always like to
go around and talk to vendors and see
what they're doing and you know it's
it's just amazing to see you know how
much traction kubernetes is getting and
all the integrations that that platform
is driven in the in the ecosystem but
now I'm talking to vendors about this
geo and so that's kind of exciting for
me yeah I think you mentioned that you
haven't had a chance to go to any of the
talks because of the number of people
that are interested in talking to you
about its TIA yeah this was always going
to be kind of the hallway track for me
this year right I mean I'm here to
represent sto and to talk about Google
and Google's use and you know how we're
pushing the service mesh story forward
so yes not a lot of talks though I am
talking tomorrow so I at least get to
attend my own session what is that about
so it's a panel just discussing you know
where service mesh is
we know what factors and forces in the
industry are driving it and where we all
think it's going and so the some folks
from liquor D right and talking about
their service mesh product some folks
from IBM me and a Zach from tetra it
will also be there sounds like it'll be
a great session for folks interested in
this do then yeah it's tomorrow around
11:40 I think well keep an eye on the
schedule and finally what's your
favorite coupon memory well so well this
is not my first Kubik on the very first
cucum I went to is actually the the kind
of the inception moment for is do you
know we were thinking internally about
building an open sort of service product
and we were looking at technologies in
the industry and we had found this kind
of site project that IBM was building
called I don't remember the name of it
now but anyway we met the project lead
for that here and we just kind of
started spitballing about you know
creating this community effort and a
rolling up together and within a week of
that meeting we had gotten these to a
project off the ground so you know I had
fond memories of coop con because that's
where st was born sto was born at Q Khan
that is awesome well it was a pleasure
talking to you thank you very much yeah
that's great thanks for all right thank
you very much
[Music]